All right, welcome back.
I'm here with my panel.
First up, Nightly Show
contributor Rory Albanese.
(applause and cheering)
And Nightly Show contributor
Franchesca Ramsey.
(applause and cheering)
You can see him
in the spring premiere episode
of Empire,
"Death Will Have Its Day,"
on Wednesday, March 30
at 9:00 p.m. on Fox.
Actor Jussie Smollett,
everybody.
(applause and cheering)
And for everyone at home,
join our conversation right now
on Twitter @NightlyShow,
using the hashtag #Tonightly.
Okay, so, we've been talking
about Trump this week.
SMOLLETT:
Oh, damn. Oh!
-And we've talked about him
every night. -SMOLLETT: Oh!
Well, here's the thing. Here's
the thing I wanted to cover.
So, the media's been
extremely Trump heavy
in their coverage
of this election.
I mean, he's gotten more
air time-- this is true--
than the entire
Democratic field
and three times more attention
than Rubio and Cruz, okay.
So, do we think Trump
is the creation of the media?
Is he the creation of media,
or is he just exploiting it?
Ooh, I think
he's just exploiting it.
-Hell, yeah.
-He's good at it, though.
I have to remind you that he had
a very mediocre television show
-filled with...
-(laughter)
-How dare you, Franchesca!
-Listen, it was full
of D-list celebrities. -Yeah.
-And it was ratings gold...
-D list?
-Um, Gary Busey. Hello!
-Oh, my God.
ALBANESE: Um, hello.
National treasure Gary Busey.
SMOLLETT: I think, though,
at the same time, though,
what we have to realize
is that yes,
he's-he's manipulating
the media,
but the media is letting him
for ratings.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I think that
we can all agree with that.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just,
and we've come into...
we're in this world right now
where we're... we're stuck
-with this reality-TV world,
-WILMORE: Yeah.
but this is...
reality TV is fun,
but not when we're talking
about the presidency
-of the United States
of America. -RAMSEY: Whoo!
-(cheering, applause) -That's
not what we're talking about.
But it's funny
that you said that,
'cause here's a quote
from Les Moonves--
he's the head of CBS now.
He says-- he's talking
about the coverage of Trump.
He says, "But, you know--
it may not be good for America,
"but it's damn good
for CBS,
that's all I got to say."
He's admitting
it's a horrible thing!
So... are we... is the media...
SMOLLETT: Yo, at least
the brother is admitting it.
-Yes. -'Cause all
the other people are like,
"Aw, yeah..." Well,
they know that it's the truth.
It's the truth. It's horrible
to say, but it's the truth.
But I feel like the media's,
like, in an abusive relationship
-with Trump, you know what
I'm saying? -RAMSEY: No.
-It's all right, baby, I'm not
gonna... -No, because to say
that they're in an abusive
relationship with Trump
would be to say
that they are being abused
and they are not victims.
The media's not victims
and Trump is not a victim.
So for that, they're not
in an abusive relationship.
But America is the victim!
We are the victim.
Of course, of course.
Or we're going to be
if we continue to be like,
Ah-ha-ha-ha, Trump,
ha-ha-ha-ha, Trump,"
until we're like,
"Holy (bleep), that's Trump,
and he's in the freakin'
White House."
WILMORE: Well,
we've been saying that, right?
Well, first of all,
let me just say this,
'cause I think through
some sort of media conglomerate,
Les Moonves is our boss.
I think what you said
is great, Les. Uh...
-(laughter) -Good call,
Mr. Moonves, uh, good...
Um, but I think... the thing
that's odd to me about this
is why we're all so surp...
I'm surprised we're so surprised
that this is the guy.
Like, our leaders are
a reflection of our society.
This is our society.
We prioritize fame,
we prioritize, like, capitalism,
-greed, all the (bleep) Trump
stands for, -Mm-hmm. Right.
and now we have him
coming to the...
-Like, this is on us, do you
know what I'm saying? -Yeah.
I agree, I agree with that,
I agree with that,
but there are different types
of prioritizing of fame
and wealth and things like that.
Are we also a nation
that supposedly prioritizes
racism and bigotry
-and building walls... -RAMSEY:
That's what built this country!
So that's really what
we're talking about.
-Know what I'm saying?
-No, I agree with you,
but I'm saying, are we a nation
that supposedly does that? No.
But historically speaking, are
we an extremely racist nation?
-Yes. Yes, we are. -That's what
we need to be talking about.
'Cause to me,
it's not about the money.
Listen, politics is about money.
At the end of the day,
that's what their job is to do.
Their job is to raise funds
for their campaign,
which is absolute bull(bleep)
to begin with anyway.
-(whooping, applause)
-But the point is...
the point is,
the point is, though,
is that their job
is to raise money.
We're talking
about more than money.
There's nothing wrong
with money.
WILMORE:
You're talking about candidates?
Yeah. What's wrong with that
is when money is then attached
to... hate.
And to me,
Trump is the mogul of hate.
WILMORE: But here-here's
the thing, Jussie.
Trump isn't raising money
and he's not spending money.
This is what I mean.
The media is
his campaign partner in this.
ALBANESE: Like, I agree--
the media is exploiting him.
WILMORE: Well, I wouldn't say
they're exploiting him.
No, I... no, I think
they are exploiting him,
'cause this... like,
we're doing it right now.
Like, this is
a money-making industry,
talking about Trump--
we're doing a show
-Very true. Very true.
-about it right now, right?
Yeah, but we were doing shows
before Trump was here,
-we'll do shows after Trump.
-But CNN was doing shows
-before Trump, too.
I'm saying right now -Right.
the way the media is run--
and it's broken,
the whole CNN, MSNBC system
is the same on
the entertainment rating system.
They just want ratings.
So Trump is the way to get
ratings, so it makes sense
that they're gonna be
talking about him 24/7.
No, I understand that,
but it's not... I mean,
it's not that clean, because
he's running for president.
-Right. -It's not like he's
just saying this crazy (bleep)
in his living room,
and some cameras showed up--
"You (bleep) got
to watch this (bleep).
I mean, he's saying
some crazy (bleep)."
But, you know, it's like,
"Who is this guy!
"Thank-thank you, CNN!
"I never would've known
about this guy.
But I'm gonna vote for him
for president."
But I'll give you... like,
I'll give you an example.
Like, you know, I was at
The Daily Show for a long time,
-when Bush became president.
-Right.
Eight years of Bush
at a comedy show--
but people were buying
summer houses on that guy.
You know what I mean?
So, like, there's a part of it
that's like, "All right,
eight years of Trump--
like, I'm getting a jet ski."
You know, like, it's, like...
See, we're all... like, you
know, there is a feeding frenzy
around the clown, and he is
the clown with tiny hands.
-We know that, you know? But...
-WILMORE: We do know that.
There's a feeding frenzy.
WILMORE: Do you think the media
plays favorites?
-What are we talking about?
What, what? -Do-do you think
the media plays favorites
outside of getting ratings,
do you think they actually play
favorites in their coverage?
Sure, I think they do,
and I think that that's the...
that's the terrible thing
about the media,
especially in this
day and age is that...
I'm sorry, I'm an absolute
1,000% liberal.
But I shouldn't
even be looking at any network
and looking at a journalist
and seeing
that they're obviously
liberal or conservative.
I actually, as a journalist,
I should be looking at
journalism and I should be
looking at news channels
as only the truth,
because there's-there's
always three sides to the story:
there's your side,
my side and the truth.
If anything, news organizations
are supposed to be
only reporting the truth
and the facts
-and we're supposed
to make our decisions. -Yeah,
it-it really does feel
like a reality show.
-Yeah. -Yeah.
-I mean, the GOP
is like an episode
of The Bachelor at this point.
I... Ben Carson is the black
girl that never had a chance.
Good-bye, I have to go.
Farewell.
Honestly. And Donald Trump
is the unhinged drama queen
who doesn't even
like the bachelor
and just wants screen time
and her own spinoff.
-Wow. -(cheering, applause)
-And that's why
-they're getting
so much attention. -So sad.
It's the exact same thing.
It's what we've been reduced to.
All right. We'll be right back.